hey Conan O'Brien here welcome to
serious jibber-jabber I'm sitting here
with Ken Burns who is arguably the most
accomplished historical documentary
filmmaker of all time his films have won
dozens of major awards including 12
Emmys three Peabody's and he has
single-handedly helped define our
history as a nation pretty heavy
introduction for you that is heavy
not bad not bad and you're a
welterweight champion I've really
thrilled to sit to sit down with you
I've been a fan for a long time as you
may have heard I'm an amateur historian
who makes his living in comedy but this
is what I like to read about this is
what I like to watch I've seen all of
your documentaries and that brings us to
the address I am a Lincoln fanatic so
I'm very happy to talk about the address
which is a fascinating idea for
documentary why don't you tell people a
little bit what it's about I've lived
for 35 years in a tiny village in New
Hampshire and across the Connecticut
River in Putney Vermont is this tiny
school called the Greenwood school it's
a boarding school for little boys ages 9
10 11 2 all the way up to 16 17 18 and
they all have dyslexia or ADHD an
alphabet soup of learning differences
and every late-november when they come
back from Thanksgiving they're asked to
memorize and then publicly recite around
Lincoln's birthday the Gettysburg
Address now this is a challenge for any
of us and we have in fact challenged the
whole country to do this but it's a
minefield of terrors and anxieties for
these kids and I was asked as a neighbor
to be a judge one year and a judge means
given award to everybody and it's I'm
tears are streaming down my cheeks when
you see these kids sort of escape the
specific gravity of the stuff that's
held them back that's gotten them
bullied and marginalized in other
schools and this is the place of last
resort and I kept coming back and I kept
talking to them about the meaning of the
Gettysburg Address other stuff been a
judge again and finally I just thought
you know cinema verite which is the
style is not my style but what am I
waiting for so
it was the 150th anniversary of the
Gettysburg Address was approaching in
2013 and I thought let's just film this
winter 2014 early 2013 attempt and we
embedded shot 300 hours of these kids
they forgot we were there we got to know
and love them and the teachers and it's
a very close-knit very funky place and
just watched the transformation of kids
who have been told they were stupid and
dumb all their lives acquiring this
thing which they will always have for
the rest of their lives and doing it
magnificently and then as a coda we
learned that the school in the 35 years
of its existence the 35 years of asking
the kids to do this had never been to
Gettysburg so I rented a bus after
throwing school showed him gave him a
tour of Gettysburg and then peeled off
the kids one by one and had him recite
it was three months later they hadn't
done anything on it and they all still
had it it was all inside it was
something that they had internalized
something they had kept and it's not
just rote memorization they had also
brought in the meaning of the words I
think we don't do that anymore in United
States we don't learn things my dad had
six hours of Shakespearean passages and
scenes and long poems and body dirty
limericks and tons of stuff right on his
hard drive and me less so and and we
don't teach anything because we said oh
it's got to be relevant there shouldn't
be rote learning and yet you see what we
could do in unison so we're now all
independent free agents and we feel
lonely and we yearn for community these
kids paradoxically get some kind of
agency free agency by doing this and
liberate themselves have a new birth of
freedom Lincoln says in the oddities of
Ring address and yet it's a free agency
connected to community to sharing their
struggles with their teachers and their
comrades and going out and showing their
families that they are somebody showing
their friends that they are somebody it
has an incredible existential thing and
then you realize the Gettysburg Address
the greatest speech ever given in the
English language is hovering over there
it's doubling down on the Declaration of
Independence it's the declarations that
all men are created equal but oops the
guy who wrote it owned other human
beings
which caused the war which caused
Lincoln to go to Gettysburg the great
site of the greatest battle and to say
this two minutes of doubling down on the
Declaration and that's been our
operating manual since then so I thought
just look at these kids but see the
context you know feel them in a way that
you don't normally do and let them you
know work their way out of this
tough tough paper bag that they're in
and Excel who know someone had the idea
at some point say these kids should
learn the Gettysburg Address yes that's
the stroke of genius to me is that
because it's a speech that everybody
talks about and you've everybody there
in New York maybe there'd been more New
Yorker cartoons about the Gettysburg
Address executive but we does this
Magana yeah exactly but then you don't
know who's lost time someone read it and
actually thought about it right and I
revisited it recently I was at an event
and I was supposed to give a speech the
next day you spoke the day before and
recited the Gettysburg Address and tried
to put meaning into each word rather
than the conventional wisdom that we
think I was furious because I had a
speech to give the next day the night
before you give the greatest speech time
and I found myself looking down at mine
thinking it's no Gettysburg Address but
it's amazing when you sit and listen to
it again how powerful it is and you know
think about it the guy who spoke before
Edward ever denoted order of the day
gave a great speech at just under two
hours two hours Lincoln gets up he
speaks less than two minutes 272 words
if you accept the Bliss version there
five different drafts of it and he
basically in the first sentence says
this is where we've been in the second
sentence says this is where we are and
the remaining eight sentences says this
is who we could be this is what we're
obligated to become this is what we have
to remember this is what we have to do
and it is so poetic and so meaningful he
uses the word here all the time he
places it like he rearranges the
furniture we here highly regarded the
world will little note nor long remember
what we say here but it can never forget
what they did here you know that we here
highly resolve that these day it it has
a kind of hypnotic sense that you're
listening clearly to political speech
but there's a kind of enduring poetry to
it I that I don't know I mean I'm drawn
to lots of speeches in history and
Lincoln's given a lot of them that are
fantastic right but this one because of
the concision because this is at a place
where they've just put nearly 10,000
bodies have died here and fifty-six
thousand casualties it's the greatest
battle ever fought on American soil it
is the defining moment of this civil war
that had to happen because of the
asterisk that the founders right
Jefferson left by saying all men are
created equal but we just mean white men
of property free of debt not anybody
else right and the fact that it has legs
the fact that on the first anniversary
of 9/11 you know we had that desperately
sad recitation of the names of the dead
I mean just just you know it's just like
somebody hitting you with a sledgehammer
right here and no contemporary speeches
just a few little words one of which was
the Gettysburg Address has nothing to do
with 9/11 but as I felt in the film is
that words are medicine you know and
particularly in our country words do
matter right you know we're formed with
words we're not formed because of
geography or religion or conquest or
economic form because we agree to
subscribe to that very deeply flawed
catechism that is the declaration but
Lincoln was the one who sort of made it
a new living he breathed new life in it
but I think a lot of people forget that
civil war begins and it's a states
rights economic struggle that's the way
many people are seeing it and Lincoln
it's at the get it you know with the
Gettysburg Address and he also did it
with the Emancipation Proclamation he
single-handedly elevating made it a
higher cause the war he's saying this is
not just about you have cotton but we
have
steam-powered more railways and that he
is making it about human rights which
you know many people resent it many
people thought that is not why we're
fighting there's no this is a hugely
important hugely important moment in
American history because and obviously
this is the most important event but for
a long time leading up to during and and
particularly after which is so sad
the descriptions of why this Evora
happened have been sort of political
states rights it's been economic it's
been you know social but when you boil
it down it has always been slavery the
social differences between a country
based on slave labor or wage based labor
is different the way you configure your
your towns your plantations your the way
you dance the way you sing the political
stuff of states rights the South was
just fearing that the North would
suddenly achieve with the addition of
Western states a kind of majority a
supermajority we'd say today that would
then prescribe things that that they
wouldn't like and the one thing they
feared was the abolition of slavery and
then they said well their economic
differences but the only economic
difference of significance was the fact
the four million American citizens who
were owned by other Americans that was
the most valuable property that the
south have and if you need to finally
put a kind of an exclamation point on
that and stop saying stop talking about
states rights stop talking about
nullification stop talking about
interposition stop talking about social
stuff and things like that go to South
Carolina's declaration of six secession
in November just after Lincoln's elected
he doesn't mention states rights but it
mentions slavery so many times that's
why the war happened but at the
beginning in order to keep the fragile
coalition together the border states
yeah and the western states and others
within you know slaves that favored
abolition and emancipation he had to say
this as a war for Union and as soon as
he had even the semblance of a major
victory which took a long time to happen
until September of 62 in the Battle of
Antietam which we look at as a draw he
nonetheless issued the Emancipation
Proclamation then on January 1st 1863
and and then six months later you have
this Battle of Gettysburg and Fordham
and a half months after that he has the
opportunity to say a few appropriate
remarks he's not the featured part of
this all right so this is the big
question one of the big questions
he gives the Gettysburg Address how does
it go over now is there any sense of how
the crowd reacted the speaker before him
Edward Everett almost two hours two
hours so he's Lee much lesser remembers
like a jazz guy he'd he'd initiate a
theme he'd go off on a huge tangent came
back to the thing people might even
applaud just the virtuosity of his
rhetorical skills and he may have no
notes in front of him yes
and so it's he is he's a headliner yeah
he's going out he does two hours and
it's verbal fireworks Lincoln gets up
and he has that not the deep baritone
that was portrayed throughout the whole
movies of all time and forth yeah yeah
he's he's got the Daniel day-lewis
sort of high reader pitch he's it's
reading exactly the read II is the right
word it's nasal it's sort of Midwestern
and it's got a little bit of twang in it
and it's been an effective tool all his
life in the court in the hundreds
thousands of court cases he tried as a
lawyer in the lincoln-douglas debates in
the Cooper Union speech so it's he's not
without the awareness of his rhetorical
powers but you're right he gets up and
there's two minutes and people are sort
of like they're essentially settling in
and he's done he's been the photographer
has taken his time to focus and the only
picture we have of Lincoln at Gettysburg
is him back in his seat on the dais and
so there's a kind of the Chicago papers
his state Illinois says the cheek of
every American must tingle with shame as
he reads the silly flat dish watery
utterances of the man who has to be
pointed out two intelligent foreigners
as the president of the United States
and whatever it writes him and says you
know I hope that I could have come in
two hours as close to the central theme
of it as you did in two minutes mr.
president and in a great compliment but
the the thing exists not in a media
culture where it's instantly you to
babble or a trip
on c-span Tyler times but it has to
exist on a piece of paper and there five
drafts and it has to be in some ways
promoted out by the newspapers that
write about it and some were very
positive about it by the commentary
word-of-mouth and then also as time
changes as Lincoln's position in our
Pantheon changes it grows with him
that's a point where we begin to go back
to those words and the first
inauguration the better angels of our
nature and the message to Congress in 62
we cannot escape history the fiery trial
through which we passed will light us
down and honor or dishonor to the latest
generation the last best hope of Earth
the second inaugural malice towards none
charity and all of a sudden you've got
this body of work that that seems to be
pure presidential poetry that were
unaccustomed to we've got good words
we've had them since and we had them
before but we didn't have them in this
way and we didn't have them with a
martyr in our most challenging moment
and yet all of that conspires to it does
very much feel like you needed time time
had to go by I think so Lincoln I don't
think it wasn't possible in his own life
that people could appreciate he might
have been the best writer of his time he
might have been the greatest intellect
of his time and I know it's in your in
your savour documentary that he was
considered you know by many one of two
geniuses at the time yeah yeah and
Shelby Foote thought Nathan Bedford
Forrest the Confederate cavalry officer
who later became horror of all Horrors
the first Grand Wizard of the Ku Klux
Klan but even quit to his partial credit
when the Klan became too violent but
Shelby Foote definition of genius
Lincoln is a genius
he wrote someone said with the bark on
the way Twain wrote to he wrote it he
wrote American he was not he was utterly
American he came out out of the soil so
that we don't feel like he's trying to
emulate his James Fenimore Cooper did a
kind of British literary tradition
mocked magnificently by Mark Twain
he's like Twain he's
just of the land he's of the people he's
special to this continent and so he's
able to contain and reflect back to us
our wishes you know the best of
ourselves it's funny he was not he
didn't have the formal education he
didn't and and everything I've read
about Lincoln said that he didn't even
consider himself a great wide reader
with a great rep or breadth of knowledge
but he said I know Shakespeare yeah he
said I know he read Shakespeare and he
knew his King James Bible yeah did King
James Bible he had all of Shakespeare
any of the law yeah and that that's sort
of a secondary thing but I think it's
really we don't do him a service if we
don't understand the way in which the
law has a kind of beauty to it we see
its today we see all of its flaws and
its mistakes and its abuses and how it
can be bought but it also has a kind of
purity to it that that and a logic to it
and if that law is issuing in a less
less complicated time but unless dense
with the verbiage it's also issuing from
the Constitution and the laws of the
state of Illinois in his case and so
there's logic and so he's thinking
through with with firm kind of rationale
one plus one equals two thinking but
he's got the Kings James Bible and
Shakespeare which are telling you always
that one plus one equals three it's this
magic alchemy that you know we of course
reject in our brains or everyday brains
of course 101 equals two but of course
what we want in our life in our comedy
in our sex in our faith in our art in
our literature in our relationships we
want one and one to equal three we want
that's the whole to be greater than the
sum of the parts and I think that he was
able to take the logic of the law and
apply it to what he was seeing
politically but then add the majesty and
the poetry of the bible and shakespeare
to give it you know purpose and a kind
of immortality i mean we wouldn't be
talking today if these 272 words didn't
just have a kind of half-life that's
almost endless I can imagine there if
there were human beings we wouldn't
still be talking some time ten
years ago about the gettysburger time
from now for about the gettysburger it's
funny it went viral before something
could go vine exactly he wrote you know
it's it's the essence of what we have
today today we have the ability for
everything to go everywhere the
challenge is finding anything that's
worthwhile or that it can endure he
gives this one speech two minutes long
there's no device there to record it
there's not even a good photograph that
we can use and there's five drafts that
are slightly different and over time it
gives you this kind of faith I think in
a way that with you if you use the words
correctly if you enunciate them if you
enunciate if they're logical and if it's
beautiful that devoid of anything that
would make something go viral it becomes
the greatest speech Eyck of all time and
i think that's what you said faith is
the key word you know we live in an age
where there's so many pictures that they
can't possibly be worth a thousand words
anymore maybe they've been devalued to
250 yeah we live in an age where
everything is covered so then nothing
has meaning yeah and so how is it that
meaning survives where do we make
meaning today out of our chaos and and
you know there's some real fundamental
existential things that are going on not
with just with these boys but in this
whole thing and not just with war it's
just we've spent our lives trying to
pretend the fact that we're not none of
us are getting out of this alive you
know and we try to keep the wolf from
the door but that wolf's always there
and we superimpose meaning over the
chaos we we tell jokes we tell stories
we put a frame around things and that's
a way of trying to create a narrative
about stuff that has no narrative and
that's the chaos of life and none of us
get out alive so when you find something
that endures it hangs on and it gives
that meaning I mean how is it that
somebody was born in 1809 for you and me
has tremendous almost transcendent
meaning as a human being who's been dead
since 1865 that's an awfully long time
ago and we're
we're you know in some ways captives of
that genius still and in a way that I
wholly submit to I'm willing to be part
of that cult of of Abraham Lincoln
so in this speech Lincoln shows us he
wrote it didn't have a you know was did
not use a speechwriter he wrote it in
his own hand he delivered it it and then
we're left with this idea of what's
happened to the speech I think about
this a lot I think about of course you
cannot you can't often tell in your own
time what's a great speech it needs time
but clearly we've had fewer and fewer
presidents in my opinion who seemed to
understand that a speech can change
everything yes John F Kennedy was not
president very long and you can have a
lot of historians line up and argue
about the value of his policies he
didn't get to do much he he had a
Congress that he that he couldn't
convince to move so he himself couldn't
point to many accomplishments but he's
got that person or that first inaugural
and it is fantastic and it's the gift
that keeps giving that's right and he
knew he and with the help of Ted
Sorensen he knew I think because he was
a fan of Churchill's yes JFK used to
listen to Churchill's speeches he'd sit
in the bathtub and listen to Churchill
speeches on phonograph records he loved
Churchill speeches and he understood
this speech really counts and the drama
of it and the meaning and the symbolism
and the connection the way Churchill did
yeah I agree and and we don't know I'm
making a film among many films on the
history of the war in Vietnam and and we
just don't know enough about what he
would have done with that and right it's
really part of the elevation of that
speech comes from unexpressed potential
unrealized potential
just like in Lincoln yeah Lincoln had
already done so much but it also the
fact that was cut short at his moment of
triumph also elevates
makes us scrutinize in a different
perhaps more sympathetic way what he did
in a way that you don't have with the
other great speech writers of which we
have been so fortunate in our country to
have we have you know it's what you're
saying which I agree with is that you
have it's two components it's the speech
but then it's the the speech alone can't
do it it also needs the situation needs
at the moment it needs the moment
Lincoln had the moment and the speech
John F Kennedy had a moment at a huge
Trent generational transition from
Eisenhower date him born in this century
tempered by war yeah this is this is
exactly right he knew the cusp that he
was on but the moment was created retro
actively that is to say the moment of
his death yeah back to the moment of the
speech and they coexist because the
speech has great rhetorical beauty to it
but it's made all that more important by
the fact of his death just as Lincoln's
not so much as death but the moment of
the greatest battle ever fought on
American soil and there's I think about
Churchill nineteen forty it really looks
like thirty nine that it seems a
foregone conclusion the Nazis are coming
they've defeated France we almost don't
really have we got what we could out of
Dunkirk but we don't have how are we
gonna be how we gonna beat this massive
omnipotent machine
the Russians are siding with them it's
almost over and Churchill gives that
speech now there's the moment and the
speech draws a line in the sand yeah
that's the ultimate one and he stood by
it he says we will fight them on the
beaches yeah and we will fight them in
the hills and befriend and that speech
people before had no hope and many
people talk about a lot of people who
are still alive say and then after he
gave that speech I thought screw him
screw them all we're gonna fight I've
been working on this series and just
finish it'll be out in the fall of 2014
on the Roosevelts Theodore Franklin and
Eleanor we put them all together and TRS
got some great speeches and FDR of
course has a famous inaugural and we
have nothing to fear but fear itself
but a few days later he goes and give
his first fireside chat that's less than
15 minutes long he explains the banking
system to everybody and at that point
there had been runs on bank thousands of
banks have already failed and people
have there been run on the banks they
declared a bank not a moratorium as
Hoover called it but a bank holiday
which is a more pleasant thing right and
he just says hoarding has become an
unfashionable pastime and put your money
back in the banks and on that when the
banks reopen that's exactly what
Americans did and and you know
essentially talk about urgency a moment
he capitalism as some wag some aid said
was saved in eight days I mean just yeah
I virtue of the power of words people
listened to them and said that's right I
will I understand what it means it was
sort of like Jimmy Stewart and it's a
wonderful life you know my that money is
in your house and we're not there it's
well yeah exactly and and and we you
know that's a that's an FDR New Deal
riff and that comes from his ability to
personalize it and say you know my life
is tied up in yours and he says that you
know this is as much your problem as it
is my problem my friend
yeah and they believe that when he died
in his and his funeral procession was
going down Pennsylvania Avenue some man
just collapse just wailing and the
person next to him stood him up and said
did you know the president he said no
but he knew me well and I thought that
was the example in which rhetoric
somehow Pierce's all of the armor of our
political system and then the armor that
we ourselves as individuals construct to
guard us from those complicated and
nuanced feeling Franklin Roosevelt
also had that gift you could not if you
wanna if you hired an actor who had a
calm reassuring voice you couldn't do
better than Franklin Roosevelt at that
time George will said the greatest New
Deal program was Franklin Roosevelt's
smile he was incapable of depression and
we were in a depression it will says and
and that's a really good way of
understanding and he had been armored he
goes on to say was sort of Christian
faith that American history was a rising
in this utterly free sense of
experimentation and so you were in the
hands of somebody who displayed not a
flash of doubt and even if something
went wrong you said okay we'll try
something else and now we're also we're
naval gazers we're all introspective
we've got a huge media apparatus that
sort of turns out conventional wisdom by
the yard of every stripe and there's
very little room to actually tolerate
movement for anybody left right or
center in a real political dynamic and
so we say well why can't we get things
done the way they used to well these
things pass by one vote or didn't pass
or the Supreme Court ruled them
unconstitutional but it really becomes a
question as we debate what the role of
government is and what a citizen can
expect of the government which is the
age-old American political question it's
also what is the nature of leadership
and what is character about where does
character and leadership intersect and
how does someone escape the specific
gravity of their own flaws Teddy
Roosevelt's feebleness as a child the
early tragedies that he had Eleanor
Roosevelt's insecurity Franklin
Roosevelt's infantile paralysis and sort
of kind of glibness I mean he's almost
sort of you know I I deserve this and
all of a sudden he's tempered by this
extraordinary event infantile paralysis
at 39 and so we like to think in this
modern age that heroes ought to be
perfect and if anything goes wrong you
go aha see it's not like the old days
but if you go back to the Greeks they
never said that heroism was about
perfection they said that heroism was
someone with some very obvious strengths
and some maybe not so obvious and
perhaps equal weaknesses and it is the
negotiation and sometimes the war
between those strengths and weaknesses
that actually define heroism so all of a
sudden if you let in that fresh air of
human reality because I haven't met a
perfect person you you're suddenly have
heroes all around you because of the
complicated dynamics they're involved in
in our relationship to them and it makes
you history makes you these words make
you more sanguine more hopeful more full
of faith and that goes back to what
you're saying it is
faith it is I think what makes the Carol
books on Lyndon Johnson so compelling is
how titanically gifted he is and how
titanically flawed he is
it's that swirly cone of vanilla and
chocolate together and they're
completely intertwined and inseparable
once the swirly cone has come out
because you can't separate Lyndon
Johnson from his flaws and this is what
we tried to do we're so dialectically
preoccupied everything's red state or
blue state it's gay or straight its
young or old it's rich or poor it's
Easter west whatever it is we like to
say male or female we know the
distinctions right between us but in
fact we find our own existence so filled
with shades of grey that this attempt to
try to put everything in a black and
white corner just never works and the
great mastery of Karos book and what
makes Lyndon Johnson one of the most
compelling figures or say Richard Nixon
- I was just thinking about Richard
Nixon here's the guy who starts the
Environmental Protection Agency
you know opens up opens the door to chop
but he's a red bader you know he get his
whole political career is based on
destroying people cuz they're not
they're too soft on communism and then
who is the guy who opens up
relationships I mean if he had not won
that election and Humphrey who probably
wouldn't have thought of this though it
would have been within his DNA who would
have been the loudest critic it would
have been Richard Nixon and we would
have looked to him for saying you know
don't you disagree with this and you
begin to see the way in which the
partisan Mis of politics is does such a
disservice it's a necessary part of it
but when you see it within some person
the wars within them within them over
well we know too much we know too much
now too because you look at you know
with Nixon every time the dust starts to
settle and people start to say you know
he did do this he did do this need to do
that they release more tape exactly more
tapes come out and he's like a dagger
and if a dagger and there's you knows
anti-semitism and there's pettiness and
smallness and I think the words devoid
of God knows what any of these people
said right in the privacy of their own
Oval Office or their own
homes and but now we just have the words
which are beautiful you know but my what
I'm curious about and I'd love to get
your opinion is I get despondent
sometimes because I don't remember I
cannot think of an inaugural address
that I've really liked I can't think of
a State of the Union address that has
moved me because I feel that they've
become containers for if it's the
Republican Party it's you've got to
throw the RNC there red meat if it's the
Democratic Party you've got to announce
all these all this policy you've got to
touch every base which doesn't make for
a great speech I usually find they're
overly long and I usually find them to
be doled out please applaud segments
that I don't find inspirational they
don't they're not elevated now I know
that I'm I'm holding them to a high
standard I I think it is partly that
because it's we live in an age in which
the tier particularly in the United
States of America where the tyranny of
choice has a huge sway over us we've got
so much commentary about stuff so many
different things that we have remember a
Moscow on the Hudson where it opens up
when Robin Williams is a struggling
musician in Moscow and he's waiting in
line for hours for he knows or not what
only to discover and that there's
nothing there left whatever it was that
he was waiting in line for that's the
tyranny of no choice right becomes the
United States he defects he you know
goes to some supermarket and the Upper
East Side and tries to buy coffee and a
guy says aisle four and he turns around
and they're 200 choices of coffee and he
faints dead away right which is the
tyranny of choice I think in some ways
it's really hard to get at these
speeches now because they are so
filtered by the political expediency
that has to be you know doled out as you
say left right and center but also
because we have so much filters as we
watch them and we don't know what's
being said in other places that's why
c-span so great to watch is because you
can actually see stuff raw and every
once in a while go I don't think I've
ever heard anyone say that's why c-span
is so great oh I see III
I just find myself you suddenly turn and
you know everybody just goes past it but
if you stop everyone so why you're
seeing somebody maybe they're at some
think-tank or maybe it is on the floor
of Congress or it's appearing or it's at
you know some Presidential Library and
there's somebody talking about it you go
wow stuff is actually happening the the
you know things are being moved along
it's not being chopped up into sound
bytes I mean that's I would submit you
know going back that barack obama has
given some great speeches george w bush
you know gave two speeches in a row in
front of a joint session of Congress and
the National Cathedral right after 9/11
that we all needed we really needed and
I guess there's no words that come out
of it that are as memorable as say Jack
Kennedy's inauguration or other things
Ronald Reagan gave some speeches you
have Kennedy's speech there four or five
I guess there were moments I think
Ronald Reagan after the Challenger after
the Chum when he was that at what do
they say the consoler in chief you know
and and if you look at the speech that
Barack Obama gave in Tucson after the
shabby different Gabby Giffords then I
thought about that recently because that
was a moment where people needed yeah
and and the it's interesting the
president comes in it's a it's it's we
don't actively elect a president to
console us at moments but that turns out
is one of the most important parts of
the genius it is the part of leadership
which we understood even at the
beginning that the role of the president
was going to be not just one of three
branches and the sort of decider of the
executive branch side of things but it
was going to have a kind of symbolic
investment that would not be royal
though we try our best to turn it into
that but that it would then have other
responsibilities you know and I think
the they're great pitfalls in that
because we think everything will succumb
to personality but at the same time when
you have the president and remember he
spoke after three or four of his own
cabinet members all of whom invoke
Scripture this is the godless Democratic
Party and the president came with three
or four lightning bolts of both old and
new Testament
were stunning for their appropriateness
to the tragedy but also making the
tragedy secondary and he's asking us all
to be to make a country that's worthy of
the little girl who went to visit her
congresswoman mm-hmm at the mall and got
murdered for her civic engagement and
it's one of the most moving speeches
ever and so I think maybe what you're
talking about is this garden doesn't
look as pretty as I thought it did in
the 18th century but what it needs is
just some weeding you need there like
there's there - what weeds in the way
you know what I get back to also is
brevity Lincoln was a master of brevity
and it's lean you just look at it as
prose or poetry because it is poetry
that's right
and when actually when he tried to write
poetry it wasn't good poetry but he's a
bad poet but when he wrote speeches they
were poetic and beautiful yeah but
they're lean and you mentioned Franklin
Roosevelt's fireside chats they could be
very completely Nestle mints where he
explained the entire banking system and
got everybody to do the exact opposite
of what they thought they were gonna do
on Friday and you look at lend-lease
with Franklin Roosevelt he's he
desperately he wants to help England he
wants to give them ships nobody in
America wants to get involved and he
comes up with he says well you know what
we're gonna do is our neighbors houses
aren't fair we're gonna let them borrow
our yeah our garden hose yeah let's go
up and borrow it what's it it's an
analogy that's beautiful but it's
completely missed completely apart when
you're giving them material of war yeah
material I'm returning this empty shell
casing I am returning this destroyed
tank it doesn't it doesn't work but it
worked beautifully what I think we'd get
away from now is I'm yearning for a
president or a major policymaker to get
up at an event and say something with
great brevity that has power yes and I
almost feel like we're in an age now
where
that's been lost and it's easy to say oh
the olden days were better I understand
that but isn't that interesting though
because we're in a place where we also
bolon the fact that everything's been
reduced to a two or three-minute youtube
kitten thing right and and and we and we
yearn for we know in our lives that all
real meaning accrues in duration that
the relationships your proudest of the
work you care the most about is the work
that has benefited from your sustained
attention and so we live in a world
where everything is interrupted by
commercials or we have an attention span
that's supposed to be that but we we we
yearn for some duration you know we say
our kids they they're going to hell in a
handbasket but they line up at midnight
to buy a Harry Potter book that's gonna
take them 24 hours to read and then
sustain reading so we both want that
brevity we have it in front of us and
yet we don't have it in the way we
wanted somebody who could like Abraham
Lincoln distill the entire essence of
what was going on I mean you can go back
to Jefferson however flawed that second
sentence of the Declaration is and say
he distilled a century of Enlightenment
thinking into one sentence and he didn't
follow John Locke and say life liberty
and property he said life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness that was a
capital H happiness he did not mean the
pursuit of objects in a marketplace of
things he meant lifelong learning in a
marketplace of ideas that if you if you
liberated people by allowing them to
govern themselves they would grow
spiritually the human evolution would
occur in a mental and spiritual and
emotional plane and our founders talked
about higher emotions not the base
emotions of sentimentality and nostalgia
and not I would suggest just living in
the rational world the safety of the
rational world where one and one is
always - but in some higher emotional
realm in which you can risk the blessing
risk the blessing of one in one equaling
three and this is a great testament to
one sentence you know and you could make
an argument when we made a film on
Jefferson and a person in the film made
an argument that he's the man of the
millennium meaning from 1,000 to 2,000
and this is a guy
and we can go also about what our media
culture does he's on Mount Rushmore
but slept with a teenage girl he owned
boobs Abraham Lincoln a depressive very
much into things of the Spirit and
spiritualism that would make Ronnie
Reagan and Nancy Reagan's consulting of
horoscopes you know sort of minor you
have Franklin Roosevelt a [ __ ]
you know wouldn't get out of Iowa today
a media that would be not turning a
blind eye to Jack Kennedy's extramarital
affairs but in fact staking them out
like Francois oh and thank goodness he
wouldn't be arriving a little minibike
but you know you wonder who would be
selected out by our media culture today
I I think we'd probably lose warren g
harding would always get elected he
looked like a president he looked
fantastic yeah Warren Harding who always
what I didn't think about presidents
they think okay I think Warren Harding
is always my vote for my least-favorite
you know I don't want to answer letters
now from the Harding it's the Harding
said well he's there are some folks who
have been reading to rehabilitate him
you a can't be rehabilitation on the
18th president and the two before him
Pierce and and Fillmore because they're
the do-nothing presidents at a time when
we need to have a civil war to avoid or
maybe we just say the Civil War was
inevitable and we need to get to Abraham
Lincoln and figure out how yet crucible
like that you know before the Civil War
when speaking about our country we said
the United States are plural we saw
ourselves as a collection of things
after the Civil War we began to use the
word nation which is a one thing and we
say today the United States is that's
ungrammatical that's ungrammatical these
people is a really good group of people
you work with right no that's not wrong
these states is no the United States is
the greatest country on Earth that was
what Lincoln was able to do by holding
that thing together for that long by
making it the higher cause he made us of
one thing and we say it to this day and
it's
grammatical thanks that's the magic I
think of history you got everybody to
you reached out to a lot of people in
the public eye and has this all recite
the Gettysburg Address you had me do it
I was amazed because I've read it many
times and I've said it out loud but I
said it we did it here after a taping
I'm sure I was gonna after a show and
I'm sitting at my desk and ready to do
it and I said okay we need to do this
now and went through it and the power of
the whole room I mean it changed every
other people in this room who were there
everybody got very quiet you could hear
a needle drop and it is incredible and
I'm sure you've seen it and cannot read
and what I liked is that you got all
kinds of different people we read it we
did a mash up you know if you go to
learn the address org I mean our idea
was as we were watching these boys
struggle we said boy if they can do it
we can do it right so we all challenged
ourselves and then we said why don't we
challenge all school kids we said why
don't we challenge everybody to do this
and so I reached out to all the living
presidents they instantaneously said yes
and did it and and we did a mash-up with
them but it also had Bill O'Reilly and
Rachel Maddow it had you at Steven
Spielberg and you know Bill Gates
it had uma Thurman and Taylor Swift and
Robin Roberts it had you know this whole
melange of people and then if you
continued on that site you got everybody
doing their entire one and all of a
sudden thousands of other Americans have
added theirs sometimes it's a class in
Alabama or Hawaii or Utah sometimes it's
a hundred year old person or a 90 year
old person or a little kid it's a father
and daughter who've gone to Gettysburg
and they've as a project together have
done it and now we're just introducing
it to the PBS system and they're gonna
ask all of their local areas that the
government the governor's the
legislators the school districts the
churches to reach out what if we did
actually something that was bottom up
not top down that was bottom up that we
did together that we could all share and
you could suddenly realize what could
you night Bill O'Reilly and Rachel
Maddow but the Gettysburg Address right
I mean I started a nonprofit called the
better angel Society it's after
Lincoln's first inaugural and he's
appealing to the better angels of our
nature and the idea is who doesn't like
Abraham Lincoln I mean you've got to be
really fringe left or right not to like
Abraham Lincoln so that means history is
a table around which we can still have a
conversation a civil conversation a
civil discourse and then maybe stuff
happens and because as the Bible says
there's nothing new Under the Sun human
nature remains the same and you can use
these historical examples to help now
you know you know you know what's
incredible is in my own personal
experience has been for 20 years I've
had an hour and night and I try and
entertain people every now and then and
it's very rare I get an opportunity to
give a speech and when I do I work
really hard on it and one or two times I
have found that it actually has more it
can have a more sustained dramatic
impact over time yes then a couple
thousand hours of television there's
something about giving a speech and
you'd think it's counterintuitive
because you'd think in an era of Twitter
and noise and technology and lights and
CGI and IMAX you'd think that the speech
would be completely displaced in spite
you know I was present at one of those
speeches that you gave
however daunted you were perhaps by my
reading of the two minutes yeah the
night war yeah yeah I thought it was one
of the finest speeches I'd ever heard
there and everyone who heard it spoke
about it for days I went up to you
afterwards and said that was about as
good a speech as I've heard because it
was so honest and so direct and so from
the heart and it was sustained it was a
half an hour of of your of who you were
and you gave the great gift of who you
were to everyone else and at the same
time brought in it an understanding of
modern media culture what the internet
is doing how it affects you what what
what your own
but instead isn't it strange isn't it
you know what I but I never ceases to
amaze me is that it's such it's as old
as Aristotle yeah or older but there's
this there's still this thing where
someone's going to get up and give a
speech and it's sacred yeah it's still
sacred and if it goes well it it's like
a pebble in the water it the Rings just
seem to emanate out from it and it's
this it's this thing where you think now
there's there is something to this
speech given yeah that is absolutely
remarkable and now it feels like we need
it more than ever or we need it at least
as much as we've ever needed it we need
people to get up and talk and I give
speeches and it's not my day job you
gave a speech that's not your day job
you do have speaking as part of what you
do right but but we need that glue we
need to be connected to one another we
need to recognize in the other that's it
we just need to recognize each other and
that just doesn't happen you know comedy
is a hugely important force in our lives
because you know Mark Twain said the
source of laughter is not joy but sorrow
there is no laughter in heaven that that
humor hits the yes-and-no of the same
thing at the same time it's that how is
that possible and we laugh at it and
what we do is we reassure ourselves and
in that reassurance there's recognition
and connection and that's what we seek
in that sort of thing and you do start
off with a joke down and speakers start
off with jokes in order to say you know
or some trope that's different you know
the one we're talking about he says four
score and seven years ago and we think
this is some manifestation of the
anachronistic it's not nobody spoke that
way he was just trying to find a new way
of saying 87 years isn't really that
long ladies and gentleman that we've
been at this saying and look where we
are and we can do better
so he's riveting their attention he's
getting their attention by saying four
score and seven years ago and all of a
sudden everybody's doing the math a
score is 20 times four that's 80 plus
seven
four score and seven eighty seven years
ago that's 1776 this is 1863 you know he
had he had them yeah right there it's
there's something about obviously we
have our MSNBC in our Fox we have our
you know there's left-leaning there's
right leaning and it's become
professional wrestling right and it's
been perfected to the point where people
intentionally don't want to understand
each other of course not because there's
no money in that there's knows no money
in in and it's on both sides okay
there's no money in people saying you
know nuanced look at the nuance in
between there's no money in it and so I
think people have a common sense speech
that would bring everybody together
would actually have to be denied by both
side abundance and and that's exactly
what happens and so that's where we feel
this kind of freefall this abyss that
we're in that is to say you might
recognize something you know I'm working
on this film on Vietnam and it's very
interesting that even people who perhaps
back in the 60s and early 70s felt a
certain way about Vietnam because of
whatever their political orientation is
now they have to feel a certain way
about Vietnam that's different and it
and they don't know anything about it in
fact we know so little about what took
place that we didn't even know who was
ruling Vietnam at the time we thought ho
Chi Minh in general
gee op we said whose name was oppan and
and they weren't there was another guy
that we learned only through recent
scholarship who was really sort of
happening running the country of the
North Vietnam so we talked about it but
we don't have any idea what we're
talking about and and when you haven't a
chance to say something in a speech or a
film or of something of length or
duration or brevity whatever it is you
you're still gonna attract the people
say ah cuz he's clearly this or he's
clearly that oh he's clearly a lefty oh
he's a conservative how could he you
know and you can just sit there and
smile and I think the good thing is is
that most of the country has a really
good smell test you know yeah they say
just look and go I'm not buying that
that was
always the bet you know that was the bet
in 1775 and it's still the bet that
American people will figure it out they
won't they won't get it right all the
time and they don't get it right and we
and we are in danger you know we you
know you go out on the street and you
ask somebody how many senators there are
and they have no idea who your two
senators no idea who's your
representative no idea how many branches
of government
I don't know 40% of graduating high
school seniors think we fought with the
Germans against the Russians in the
Second World War majority of high school
seniors can't tell you the correct half
century in which the Civil War took
place they don't they can't put in
chronological order and tell the
significance of the Declaration of
Independence the Emancipation
Proclamation and the Bill of Rights I
mean we've got we live in a in a in a
kind of consumer culture in an in a sort
of completely disposable present where
if you just buy you can buy your
happiness but of course the inevitable
vicissitudes are going to visit all of
us and what are you gonna fall back on
yeah and I think what happens if you
have an uninformed electorate or an
increasingly uninformed electorate it's
easier for the propagandists to say what
they want to say United States
government is an evil force you know in
fact the United States government for
all its screw-ups over time has done
some pretty great things starting with
the Constitution and the Bill of Rights
through man on the moon and GI Bill and
interstate highway system and Social
Security and national parks and
land-grant colleges and homestead acts
and Transcontinental Merit railroads
this is not such a bad thing we've done
a lot of good terrible things and I've
tried in my film to show them but to a
priori say government is and of itself
bad means that you wake up in any
election cycle having to disprove a
negative and that's a tough place to be
in and and and there are people who
benefit from the largesse of this
government who are anti-government oh
yeah oh no who wake up on January 1st
with you know eighty thousand dollars or
eight hundred thousand dollars or eight
million dollars not to plant something
and they're complaining about some
mother who's put a thumb on the scale
because she said she has to
he only has one to get the extra $6.50 a
month for for the welfare thing and so
we're in that divided territory
forgetting we're all benefits benefiting
from the largesse of this government in
somewhere well I think sometimes the a
lot of the discourse is just people
wanting to belong on both sides yeah of
course the there are people that I grew
up in an Irish Catholic family and I was
confronted by people who who were
wearing the fact that they were Irish on
their sleeve now if you'd actually say
to them dude what do you know about
Ireland do you know anything about your
family they didn't know anything they
wanted to wear they wanted to wear a
tweed hat yeah they wanted to drink
Guinness they wanted to talk about how
the Irish were the best goddamn people
in the world and slap your heart on the
back and it was about that Finn and have
their black moods and have their yeah
yeah all of them and then I realized at
a certain point oh you know a lot of
these people at this st. Patrick's Day
parade and bought there's a lot of
people here that just wanna belong
that's it and then that's where you get
the same thing of you know that is
exactly Fox News or I'm MSNBC that's who
I am it's it's an emblem it's a it's
it's yeah Signia it's the colours of
your team it's the Crips and the blood
yeah exactly and they're gonna battle it
out so you have we have to look for some
sort of and it's not centrist the
mistake is to think it's centrist that
the center is important but it is the
place in which you can have a
conversation and you can compromise yeah
that's the essence of it I mean the
civil war happened because compromise
broke down people are uncompromising and
so we murdered each other and you don't
want to see that happen again we have a
question from the internet patrick from
facebook asks have you ever considered a
documentary on the history of comedy I
have actually many many times and there
have been people who have worked in
public television doing things like that
there was a series called make em laugh
a few years ago by a really good
filmmaker named Michael Cantor that's
nice of course at the same time I want
to tell stories and so I would submit
that even in the darkest films that I've
made there's always humor there's always
room to perm
humor to take place you know in the
middle of a civil war you know we
started writing about some of the stuff
you know Abraham Lincoln said if he ever
saw a man uglier than himself he'd shoot
the wretch and put him out of his misery
u.s. grant said he knew only two tunes
one was Yankee Doodle and the other
wasn't here there wasn't no um William
Tecumseh Sherman hated newspaperman so
much he said that if I killed them all
there'd be news from Hell before
breakfast though there's the the Civil
War documentary is I was always
impressed packed with really funny
it has moments and it's and just the
incredible irony of so much of it and
that and the generals the northern
generals are comical in their ineptitude
a rotation of idiots that plays there
from McDowell and McClellan and and
Burnside who said his dispatches back to
Lincoln you know headquarters in the
saddle and Lincoln said he had his
headquarters where his hindquarters
ought to be and I mean just there who's
the general was at Burnside there's one
one of my favorite quotes of Lincoln's
is if he a general lost his nerve in a
battle and I'm wondering I can't member
Fritz Burnside or not it's but Lincoln
said he behaved like a duck that had
been hit over the head yeah yeah I
thought that is hooker hooker I was
hooker in the peninsular came yeah but I
I've thought about I could say that I
could have said that tonight on the air
yeah I could have said that is a joke
from 1862 that is still works works
today I could say what was wrong and II
could say what's wrong with that gonna
get sadder now he's acting like a you
know you hit a duck over the head yeah
duck that was hit over the head and it's
a such a funny pure imitating you know
when McClellan was asking for more and
more troops Lincoln said sending him
troops was like shoveling fleas across a
barnyard
yeah and it's instantaneously an image
and the greatest one-liner I thought of
the 19th century comes from Twain he
said it's not that the world is filled
with fools
it's just that lightning isn't
distributed right and you know if you
think about other 19th century humorous
and there are several you know they're
not funny anymore their topic waited 20
funny always fun
and still funny and you know he said the
difference between the right word and
almost the right word is the difference
between lightning and the lightning bug
and that's not funny it's just really
true and he never wrote a bad sentence
and so you can you can pick up Twain
anywhere innocents abroad you know you
know obviously Huckleberry Finn but but
the the prose things roughing it and a
life on the Mississippi and just start
reading and come across some of the most
beautifully constructed things and he
like Lincoln wrote with the bark on that
is a sounded American didn't felt like
there was artifice that you had to
pretty it up or do you know do something
he would just who he was he was also
maybe our first stand-up comic Oh
without a doubt he once said he wants to
this thing where hey I don't remember
where it was but he was on this long
tour and and people loved him already
from the books and from the how his
humor and the humor in the books in the
humor and his stand-up stuff and he go
and he just went out in front of an
audience and decided just to test it and
he didn't say anything he didn't say
anything he didn't say anything somebody
started to laugh another person started
to laugh and he still wouldn't say
anything and all of a sudden the whole
place was just going crazy with laughter
and he just said I did it you know I had
I was like in Worcester or something
like that
I know Worcester my view of you know
people are from was you played Worcester
yeah I wouldn't work in Worcester now
this has been an absolute thrill this
has been great I and I'm really looking
forward to the the Franklin and Teddy
and Eleanor Roosevelt series when is
that going to be out it's taking over an
entire week of primetime PBS starting
September 14th it's the first time
that's ever happened Sunday through
Saturday the 7 episodes each two hours
but they'll repeat each episode twice
did any one of the three of them did it
did anyone surprised you the most
between Teddy Roosevelt Eleanor and
Franklin you know they all surprised me
because in one way or another they they
bloated what my preconception was um
Theodore Roosevelt turned out to be much
more unstable but so lovably soul that
that I hadn't understood that the
Eleanor turned out to be with exception
of prohibition and you could understand
it cuz her father was alcoholic and she
was sent as an orphan to be with
alcoholic uncles and hers her younger
brother who she felt responsible for
died of alcoholism she was for
prohibition but she was right on
everything else everything else every
issue she was right and usually a way
way ahead of her time
ahead of time too much of the irritation
of her husband and as a Lincoln guy who
puts Lincoln at the very top franklin
roosevelt rose up in parity to him and i
never thought i would say that really
her life i never thought you know he
handled the two greatest crises since
the civil war which was our greatest
crises but it's not about that it's
about all of the things the crucible of
polio the ability to lead the the the
sheer willpower I mean if you look at
the oldest picture you can think of
Teddy Roosevelt he died at age sixty I'm
sixty he looked like he was 85 yeah
Franklin Roosevelt died at 63 he looked
like he was a cadaver like he's 95 and
they just gave their lives for this
country and if you think of getting
through the Depression and the Second
World War and the kind of world we live
in now for better and for worse that
Franklin Roosevelt delivered following
on the work of his fifth cousin Theodore
that is to say a progressive activist
big government agenda one as a
Republican ironically and one as a
Democrat
this is the world we live in and no
other family has had a greater effect on
more Americans than the Roosevelt period
full stop I'll defend that I'm I'm
really looking forward to it I came I
just yeah I'm gonna I'll camp out yes
I'd you're home I have read I've read so
much about and in recent years more
about Theodore Roosevelt yes ton about
Theodore Roosevelt and my theory is that
he was manic I have a theory that he was
everybody in that side of the family
that's where most of the alcoholism and
madness and all of that came from and
what
he experienced he was manic as was
Eleanor they had to keep moving and when
his wife and mother died on the same day
in the same house February 14th in the
1884 I think it was and that dark day in
his diary writes an X on it yeah he goes
out to the Badlands and he says this
great nineteenth-century line he says
black care capital B capital C can
rarely catch up to a rider whose pace is
fast enough meaning you can outrun your
demons so what he and Eleanor did all
their lives was to escape the specific
gravity of the hellhounds that of
madness of alcoholism of excess that are
always on their heels and they do a damn
good job of it Franklin comes from a
much sort of saner side of the family
the Hudson River branch but he's been
stricken you know as this optimistic kid
who's been loved beg hands I was tall
and some live yeah everything and all of
a sudden he can't outrun his demons so
the kind of transformation that I
believe took place within the soul of
Franklin Roosevelt is one of the most
amazing things and it doesn't matter
what your politics are because when you
see leadership at that level of that
caliber you you can only think of one
other name in American history look to
George Washington and Abraham Lincoln
but what you're essentially saying which
is something that I agree with 100%
which is that people that are out
running darkness we come from this era
where people say you need to you're
you're in denial right and you didn't
that's the favorite phrase the last 20
30 years is you're in denial and my
father once said to me you know denials
done some pretty amazing things it has
done and it is exactly that and it's you
look at that you know the Roosevelt
people and maybe many of the great
people look at Lincoln Lincoln all the
tragedies he suffered in the poverty
that denial yeah can accomplish amazing
things I agree and I think we should end
on that note which is to tell all young
people denial denial denial denial Ken
Burns I cannot thank you enough this is
been a complete joy for more serious
jibber jabbers others in this series go
to team
koco.com slash serious thank you so much
this is great this is fun fantastic